all right let's speak to a few more
people via discord you can join at
davidpakman.com
discord
let's go next to eva from boston eva
from boston your next up uh what's going
on today what's on your mind
hi david can you hear me
yes i can
okay great um
so you know i'm having a good day it's
my first time getting on to call you so
i'm happy i'm getting the chance um good
i had a question about afghanistan so
since saudi arabia recently started
things that we're doing more progressive
not where we would want them to be
obviously but you know they're allowing
women to drive
do you think that if we never went into
afghanistan or if we left maybe 10 years
ago that
they would
naturally progress towards
progressiveness as we see a lot of these
like more conservative countries tend to
do over the years and additionally what
major legislation would
you do with that money if we never went
into afghanistan or we left after maybe
10 years
well the second part is is you know
there's no specific legislation it's all
the things we've been talking about
already
that they love to say well how are we
going to pay for that they'd be saying
it anyway but you know we're talking
about expanding health care improving
education uh advancing alternative and
renewable energy the list would be the
same it's just we would have one more uh
one more sort of like uh uh tranche of
money available but they would still say
we we don't have the money to pay for it
in terms of whether afghanistan would
have sort of naturally on its own
um liberalized had we never gone in or
left 10 years ago it's an impossible
question i think it's it's completely
impossible to say there are some
countries where that has been the
direction and others where it hasn't but
i think what's important to know about
saudi arabia and i recently read a good
book about it about
the rise of muhammad bin salman is that
there's a big component of it that's
basically marketing and optics where
it's in order to be able to get
saudi arabia wants to diversify away
from oil
and they want to take the oil money and
invest elsewhere like in hollywood films
and in dot com startups tech startups
etc
and in order to be better seen in that
world
they've done some of the liberalization
and so i'm not saying it's not in good
faith or that it is but i think there's
a big aspect of this that's to their
advantage for their financial goals and
so i have no idea in afghanistan is a
very different situation but
i don't think we would be any worse off
had we left 10 12 14 16 18 years ago
yeah i mean i'd have preferred to see us
leave
maybe never have gone in but i don't
know i was too young to really
understand what was going on in that
time but thanks for taking my call i
love seeing people of the latin culture
um represent themselves especially
after the changing census i'm really
excited to hear about that either and uh
last question what's your favorite
lesser known mexican dish because mine
is uh mole and menudo
i don't know that i you know i i am not
fully a connoisseur of uh mexican food
so i don't know that i have anything
unique to really put forward there but i
like all of it
thanks so much
all right thanks eva uh eva from boston
great to hear from her
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance i love using free trials
because i know i won't be charged when
the trial is over if i use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free and like i
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman